Oriente Medio, otra vez, vuelve a estar en
boca de todos.
Y como si el tiempo no avanzase, otra vez,
Israel vuelve a ser el epicentro del conflicto.
Queridos amigos, amigas, sí, Israel vuelve
a estar otra vez en guerra.
(Israel declara formalmente la guerra a Hamás
en su lucha por expulsar a los militantes
de su territorio.
CNN)
Una gran movilización para acabar con un
grupo terrorista.
No es la primera vez que algo así ocurre.
En 1982 y en 2006 lanzó dos guerras contra
el Libano para intentar acabar, respectivamente,
con la Organización para la Liberación Palestina
y con Hezbollah.
Pero, ¿y si os dijera que este berenjenal
que se ha montado podría llegar a convertirse
en toda una guerra abierta entre varios países?
Seguramente no os pille por sorpresa, al fin
y al cabo, no sería la primera vez que sucede
en Oriente Medio ni a Israel en específico.
Pero, os hago una pregunta: ¿qué país podría
ser el primero en declararle la guerra al
Estado hebreo?
Pues, muy seguramente, el que ya está llamando
a la puerta:
N2 (El aviso de Irán a la ONU: “Si Israel
invade Gaza, intervendremos.
Tenemos el dedo en el gatillo”.
El Español)
Efectivamente, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
Irán ya ha enviado algunos avisos sobre una
posible guerra con Israel.
Y esto no es moco de pavo.
Pensadlo bien, Irán es una de las tres potencias
regionales de Oriente Medio junto a Israel
y Arabia Saudita, y cuenta con una capacidad
militar nada desdeñable.
Sin embargo, si bien esto supondría un fuerte
shock a nivel internacional, los analistas
ya están alertando de una posibilidad especialmente
preocupante.
Si Irán llegara a entrar en guerra con Israel,
lo más seguro es que Estados Unidos se vería
arrastrado al conflicto.
Y, para muchos, este sería el preámbulo
de un conflicto mucho mayor.
Y eso ha hecho que aquí en VisualPolitik
nos hagamos unas cuantas preguntas:
¿Cómo han sido las relaciones entre Irán
y Estados Unidos?
¿Por qué preocupa tanto a Estados Unidos
una posible intervención de Irán en Israel?
¿Llegaría realmente Estados Unidos a atacar
a la República Islámica?
Y, aún más importante, ¿tendría éxito?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas, pero
antes empecemos la historia por el principio.
T1 (EN CAÍDA LIBRE)
Que Irán y Estados Unidos se desprecian no
es nada nuevo, llevan varias décadas así.
Sin embargo, no siempre fue así.
De hecho, hubo un tiempo en que fueron buenos
amigos.
Sin embargo, todo cambio, como ya os podéis
imaginar, con la Revolución Islámica de
1979.
(10 años después de que Irán se independizara
en 1943, Estados Unidos comenzó a acercarse
a Irán tras ayudar a un grupo de militares
iraníes a dar un golpe de Estado y derrocar
al primer ministro Mohammed Mossadeq, después
de que este nacionalizara la Compañía de
Petróleos Anglo-Persa.
Desde aquel momento, el Shah Reza Pahlavi,
tremendamente impopular entre la población
iraní, pero con un fuerte apoyo del tío
Sam, llegó al poder.
Fue entonces cuando la amistad entre Irán
y Estados Unidos comenzó a florecer.
Por ejemplo, en 1954, el Shah concedió un
permiso de 25 años a empresas petrolíferas
estadounidenses para que explotaran parte
del petróleo nacionalizado.
Más tarde, en 1957, ambos firmaron un acuerdo
de cooperación nuclear que se convirtió
en la base del programa nuclear de Irán y
que le permitió conseguir su primer reactor
nuclear en 1967.
Y, no solo eso: en 1972, durante una visita
del presidente Richard Nixon al Shah, Estados
Unidos prometió permitir a Irán la compra
de sistemas de armas no nucleares si se comprometía
a proteger los intereses de Estados Unidos
frente a la Unión Soviética en Oriente Medio.)
No obstante, llegó 1979 y la Revolución
Islámica dio un giro de 180 grados a esta
bonita amistad.
El ayatolá Jomeini llegó al poder, Irán
se convirtió en una República Islámica
y Estados Unidos en su principal enemigo junto
a Israel.
Desde entonces, su relación fue cuesta abajo
y sin frenos: por ejemplo, en los dos primeros
años del régimen islámico, entre 1979 y
1981, Estados Unidos tuvo que afrontar la
crisis de los rehenes americanos en Irán.
Más tarde, Washington apoyó a Irak en la
guerra que Saddam Hussein desencadenó contra
el régimen del ayatolá entre 1980 y 1988.
Entre tanto, a Estados Unidos no le tembló
el pulso a la hora de imponer sanciones a
Irán.
Y en 2002, poco después de los ataques terroristas
al World Trade Center en Nueva York, el expresidente
Bush incluyó a Irán, junto a Irak y Corea
del Norte, en lo que denominó el “eje del
mal”:
De mal
en peor.
Sin embargo, hubo un momento de calma en toda
esta tensión.
En 2015, 10 años después de que se descubriera
el programa nuclear clandestino de Irán,
Estados Unidos, la República Islámica y
otros países europeos firmaron el famoso
Plan de Acción Integral Conjunto.
Un plan que limitaba la capacidad nuclear
que Irán podía desarrollar y la sometía
a una estricta vigilancia.
Plan que pocos años después se fue al traste.
Así que, ya lo veis, en general, la relación
entre Irán y Estados Unidos en las últimas
4 décadas ha estado plagada de tensión.
Sí, es cierto, se han dado algún respiro
temporal, pero la realidad es que las hostilidades
nunca han cesado.
Y, de hecho, estos últimos años han empeorado
aún más la situación.
Prestad mucha atención.
T2 (UN CÚMULO DE PROBLEMAS)
Seguramente, fueron muchos los que pensaron
allá por el 2018 que bueno, Irán y Estados
Unidos, al menos, habían entrado en un espacio
de calma con el Plan de Acción Integral Conjunto.
Sin embargo, si algo nos ha mostrado el mundo
estos últimos años es que no podemos dar
nada por sentado.
Y justo eso fue lo que sucedió con aquella
aparente calma entre Estados Unidos e Irán,
que acabó saltando por los aires:
N3 (Trump abandona el acuerdo nuclear con
Irán que tanto despreció.
NYTimes)
Efectivamente, Trump abandonó el programa
que había puesto algo de paz entre Estados
Unidos e Irán.
El expresidente no iba a tolerar más “amenazas
vacías” del régimen islamista, según
el mismo dijo.
No tardó en imponer nuevas y duras sanciones
al régimen, esperando que Irán parara su
programa nuclear.
Sin embargo, ¿adivináis lo que hizo Irán
desde ese momento?
Efectivamente, dejar del cumplir el acuerdo
por completo.
El país de los Ayatolás intensificó el
enriquecimiento de uranio hasta tal punto
que, en 2019, la Agencia Internacional de
la Energía Atómica alertó de que Irán
ya había conseguido un enriquecimiento del
84%.
Para que os hagáis una idea, un arma nuclear
necesita de un uranio enriquecido al 90%.
Es decir, que en 2019 ya estaban a punto de
conseguirlo.
Por eso, empezaron a saltar un montón de
voces dando la alarma:
C1 ("Ya no tenemos la distancia de seguridad
de un año de ruptura para llegar a la energía
nuclear.
Irán está a dos semanas de la ruptura, a
un paso de llegar al 90 por ciento de uranio
enriquecido, cantidad suficiente para una
bomba.
Para...
transformar la bomba en un arma y completar
su adaptación a una ojiva para un misil - se
necesitan unos dos años más" - General de
Brigada Oren Setter, jefe retirado del Directorio
de estrategia de las Fuerzas de Defensa de
Israel.)
Frente a esto, la administración Biden, que
intentó retomar las negociaciones con Irán
sobre el acuerdo nuclear, ha continuado con
las sanciones contra el régimen iraní, intentando
aislarlo aún más internacionalmente.
Sin embargo, esto ha acabado reforzando amistades
que Estados Unidos prefiere debilitar, como
la amistad de Irán con Rusia.
Y es que veréis, aunque Irán habría preferido
estrechar lazos con China, las sanciones internacionales
han resultado un incómodo obstáculo para
sus relaciones, ya que China no quiere arriesgarse
a perder el enorme comercio que comparte con
los países occidentes.
Por esa razón, Irán ha optado por reforzar
vínculos con Rusia, otro “paria” internacional
azotado por también por un montón de sanciones.
En un principio, la cooperación entre estos
dos países fue fundamentalmente en materia
energética.
Sin embargo, la guerra de Rusia con Ucrania
ha expandido esta cooperación a otros campos
estratégicos.
Fijaos.
N4 (Guerra de Ucrania: EE.UU. dice que Irán
es ahora el "principal apoyo militar" de Rusia.
BBC)
Desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa a Ucrania,
Irán ha sido capaz de enviar, según fuentes
del gobierno ucraniano, cerca de 2.400 drones
a Rusia.
Hablamos, en este caso, de drones “kamikaze”
modelo Shaheb-131 y 136, que ayudan enormemente
a los esfuerzos rusos en Ucrania, especialmente
por su relación calidad-precio.
Hay que tener en cuenta que, mientras la producción
de cada uno de estos drones cuesta en torno
a los $2.000, derribarlos le cuesta a Ucrania,
de media, entre $14.000 y $15.000.
Por eso, ambos países se han comprometido
a construir una fábrica de drones dentro
de Rusia.
Vale, está bien, Irán le está siendo muy
útil a Rusia, pero ¿qué saca Teherán de
su acercamiento a Moscú?
Bueno, creo que podemos decir que este movimiento
del régimen iraní es más bien una inversión
a largo plazo en la potencia rusa.
Sí, es cierto, Irán va a recibir cazas avanzados,
helicópteros y sistemas de defensa antiaéreos.
Incluso está interesado en aprender a esquivar
las sanciones occidentales como ha hecho Rusia.
Pero, sobre todo, Irán busca en Rusia protección
en las organizaciones internacionales y, más
en específico, protección frente a Estados
Unidos y la Unión Europea.
No obstante, quizás la mayor preocupación
del gobierno estadounidense, dadas las circunstancias
en Oriente Medio e Israel, no sea ni el programa
nuclear de Irán ni su amistad con Rusia,
sino los aliados con los que cuenta este país
en la región.
Y es que, veréis, cuando Irán quiere atacar
un país, no lo hace directamente, sino a
través de grupos terroristas a los que financia
intensamente.
El mejor ejemplo de esto es Hezbollah.
Hezbollah, del que ya os hemos hablado en
este canal, es un grupo terrorista y partido
político libanés que nació durante la guerra
civil del país entre 1975 y 1990, y que recibe
tanto miles de misiles como cientos de millones
de dólares cada año desde Irán.
Hezbollah se ha acabado convirtiendo en el
aliado más importante de Irán en Oriente
Medio, ya que controla casi todos los aspectos
del Líbano, un país fronterizo con Israel.
De hecho, esta organización ya ha tenido
un montón de rifirrafes con Israel en los
últimos tiempos.
N5 (La frontera norte se calienta con nuevos
disparos de cohetes y ataques de Hezbolá
contra puestos de las Fuerzas de Defensa de
Israel.
TimesofIsrael)
Por el momento, Hezbollah no se ha atrevido
a atacar a Israel a gran escala ni tampoco
a declararle la guerra.
Sin embargo, el protagonista del nuevo conflicto
con el Estado hebreo, Hamás, también tiene
fuertes vínculos con Irán.
Es cierto que Irán no es tan cercano a Hamás
como lo es con Hezbollah, pero, aún así,
su cooperación se remonta a los años 90,
momento en que la República Islámica comenzó
a financiar al grupo terrorista palestino
con más de $50 millones anuales y armas que
ha estado enviando a través de Hezbollah.
De hecho, en 2012, Hamás comenzó a bombardear
Tel Aviv con misiles iraníes de largo alcance
Fajr-5.
De hecho, dadas las circunstancias, y tal
y como os hemos contado aquí en VisualPolitik,
en estos momentos muchos creen que Irán ha
estado detrás del ataque terrorista de Hamás
contra Israel del pasado 7 de octubre.
Pero ¿qué pasaría si se confirmara que
Irán estuvo detrás del atentado a Israel?
Y, aún más importante, ¿podría Estados
Unidos dar el paso e intervenir militarmente
en Irán?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T3 (IRÁN, ¿PRÓXIMO OBJETIVO AMERICANO?)
Ya os hemos contado que hay ciertas voces
que sospechan que Irán estuvo detrás de
los atentados contra Israel a principio del
mes de octubre.
El gobierno de Israel también lo cree firmemente.
Y la verdad es que todo apunta a que fue así.
Sin embargo, desde Washington afirman que,
bueno, que todavía no hay pruebas sólidas
que confirmen la participación ira ní en
el atentado terrorista de Hamás.
Pero, independientemente de si Irán tuvo
algo que ver o no, lo que sí ha dejado claro
es que, de continuar la respuesta israelí
contra Hamás en Gaza, no dudarían en intervenir
y comenzar un conflicto abierto contra Israel.
Para muchos, esto llevaría a que Estados
Unidos se uniera al conflicto en favor de
Israel directamente.
Pero ¿por qué?
¿Qué importancia tiene Israel para Estados
Unidos?
Pues, veréis, además de ser uno de sus mejores
aliados, Israel ha tenido una importancia
estratégica crucial para Estados Unidos desde
1967.
En la Guerra Fría le sirvió como una especie
de dique de contención, de base avanzada
frente a la influencia soviética en Oriente
Medio.
Y hoy, en cierto modo, lo es frente al radicalismo
islámico y a las potencias que pretenden
socavar los intereses del tío Sam.
Israel comparte su experiencia, información
de inteligencia, y llegado el caso es toda
una Esparta preparada para cualquier contingencia.
Por eso, su cooperación económica, militar
y tecnológica ha sido tan intensa.
Pocas dudas de que si Irán atacará Israel,
Estados Unidos intervendría en el conflicto.
Eso sí, en estos últimos años, cuando Israel
ha chocado con Irán, la respuesta ha sido
directamente israelí, y ha sido contundente:
N6 (10 de mayo de 2018) Israel lanza un ataque
militar masivo contra objetivos iraníes en
Siria.
WashingtonPost)
Sin embargo, actualmente la preocupación
norteamericana por un ataque iraní sobre
Israel va más allá de un posible ataque
con misiles.
Ahora, hay otro factor totalmente determinante
que tiene en vilo a Estados Unidos y a todo
Oriente Medio: una posible Irán nuclear.
(Y es que, veréis, si bien es cierto que
los expertos indican que Irán puede tener
ya en su posesión suficiente uranio enriquecido
al 90%, estos aseguran que aún tardaría
entre 6 y 24 meses para poder desarrollar
un arma nuclear.
No obstante, y aunque la inteligencia de Estados
Unidos asegure que Irán no reabrió su programa
de desarrollo de armas nucleares en 2022,
la realidad es que no podemos estar del todo
seguros en cuanto a si Irán cuenta ya con
algún arma nuclear o no.
Hay que tener en cuenta que, desde que Estados
Unidos se retiró del Plan de Acción Integral
Conjunto en 2018, la transparencia iraní
en materia nuclear ha sido casi nula.
Y, no solo eso, también debemos tener en
mente que el ensamblaje de un arma nuclear
puede hacerse perfectamente bajo tierra, haciendo
con ello inútiles los análisis por satélite.)
Y evidentemente, como os podéis imaginar,
Israel tiene especial temor a esta situación
que podría significar con mucha diferencia
la principal amenaza existencial sobre el
país.
De hecho, por eso mismo el primer ministro
Netanyahu ya declaró esto hace tan solo unos
meses:
C2 ("¿Cómo se impide que una nación canalla
adquiera armas nucleares?
(...) Tuvieron una que se llama el Irak de
Saddam Hussein.
Fue detenido por la fuerza militar, la nuestra.
Hubo otra llamada Siria que intentó desarrollar
armas nucleares.
Y fue detenido por una acción militar, la
nuestra" - Netanyahu, 24 de febrero de 2023.)Este
escenario tan sumamente hostil, con la posibilidad
de que una Irán potencialmente nuclear pudiera
llegar a atacar a Israel, es algo que tiene
de los nervios a mucha gente en Washington.
Y lo cierto es que el tema iraní se está
poniendo al rojo vivo: el apresamiento de
petroleros, su apoyo a Rusia, su participación
en el ataque a Israel y la posible bomba nuclear.
Empiezan a sobrar los motivos para que la
cosa pase a mayores.
Y de hecho, muchos analistas ya se plantean
la posibilidad de que Estados Unidos intervenga
si la violencia escala en la región.
Pero ¿tendría su intervención en Irán
éxito?
Por el momento, la administración Biden ya
ha decidido ir preparándose para un posible
conflicto:
N7 (EE.UU. enviará su segundo portaaviones
al Mediterráneo oriental.
El USS Eisenhower se unirá al USS Ford frente
a Israel.
ABC News)
Claro que en caso de querer atacar a Irán,
lo más probable es que Estados Unidos necesitaría
mucho más que dos portaaviones…
Pero en la región hay mucho equipo norteamericano,
incluyendo una enorme base aérea en Qatar.
Y es que tenemos que tener en cuenta que Irán
cuenta con los mayores arsenales tanto de
misiles balísticos de largo alcance como
de drones de todo Oriente Medio, y su ejército
está entre los 20 más poderosos del mundo,
superando en algunas métricas incluso al
de Israel.
Sin embargo, Estados Unidos sigue siendo con
mucha diferencia la primera potencia militar
del mundo.
Si sois fieles seguidores de VisualPolitik
sabéis que, aunque no este en su mejor momento,
el ejército del tío Sam sigue siendo prácticamente
imbatible.
Por eso, no es una locura pensar que podría
destruir fácilmente instalaciones clave,
como las de producción de armas y drones,
o las de enriquecimiento de uranio.
Sin embargo, Estados Unidos tendría que tener
mucho cuidado, porque hay una muy alta posibilidad
de que los costes de su posible intervención
superaran con creces a los beneficios.
Y, os preguntaréis, ¿por qué?
Pues veréis, si Estados Unidos interviniera,
tanto Irán como sus aliados, como Hezbollah,
no dudarían en atacar, de manera rápida
y directa, tanto las bases americanas en la
región como a Israel.
Pero, no solo eso, también se correría el
riesgo de que Irán cerrara por completo el
estrecho de Hormuz, causando, muy posiblemente,
otra grave crisis energética y económica
a nivel mundial.
Así que, ya lo veis, mis queridos amigos
de VisualPolitik.
Las relaciones entre Irán y Estados Unidos
llevan siendo hostiles más de 40 años, y
en estos últimos años han ido a peor: el
fortalecimiento del programa nuclear iraní,
el apoyo a Rusia en Ucrania y ahora la amenaza
de atacar Israel han hundido en lo más profundo
la relación entre ambos.
Los analistas ya están planteando la posibilidad
de que Estados Unidos llegue a intervenir
en Irán llegado el caso.
Tiene la fuerza militar y el apoyo de Israel
en Oriente Medio, pero, siendo honestos, no
sería coser y cantar.
De momento, el conflicto entre Israel y Hamás
parece estar en sus primeras etapas.
Solo el tiempo nos dirá si Irán acaba cumpliendo
su amenaza y si hay respuesta de Estados Unidos.
Mientras tanto, el turno ahora es para vosotros:
¿tendría Estados Unidos éxito a la hora
de atacar Irán?
¿Sería capaz el tío Sam de regar de dinero
a Israel a la par que a Ucrania?
¿Afectará esto también al desenlace del
conflicto en Ucrania?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, no olvidéis que aquí en VisualPolitik
sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas así
que suscribíos a este canal y dadle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un saludo y hasta pronto.